deadly solar flares
Planet destroying asteroid strikes or a
hostile alien takeover these might be
what comes to mind when you think of the
most dangerous threats to Earth from
outer space but the biggest threat could
be
microscopically small
why is NASA so worried about space
microbes
how much damage could an
extraterrestrial microorganism do here
on Earth
and if we aren't careful how would we
wipe out life on other planets
this is what if and here's what would
happen if the next pandemic came from
space
there are somewhere between 100 and 200
billion galaxies in the observable
universe
while we haven't discovered life on
another planet just yet there is a
staggering number of Worlds where it
could exist if the conditions were just
right
and that's why NASA and other space
agencies take the potential
contamination between our world and
other planets very seriously
I mean after all the last thing we want
to do is Discover Life Among the Stars
only to find that we put it there
scientists call this forward
contamination
terrestrial microscopic organisms from
our world could arrive on other planets
moons or asteroids by catching a ride on
equipment that someone didn't clean
thoroughly
if it's a mission to Mars or Jupiter's
moon Europa where conditions for life
are theoretically possible contamination
protocols get even stricter
but another form of contamination is
possible
backward contamination
we could unknowingly bring back
extraterrestrial microbes from space or
these life forms could spread across the
universe naturally hitching rides on
meteoroids comets or even space dust
this Theory known as panspermia might
even explain how life traveled the
universe and arrived on Earth in the
first place
but where life can go it can also
destroy
while we could face deadly exposure in
the vast expanse of space there's
another kind of dangerous exposure out
there online yeah the other day I was
Googling my own name because that's what
I do and I came across some pictures of
myself some stuff from what if and then
a bunch of information about myself and
my family that probably shouldn't be out
there you know it's unnerving to see
your private life out there for anyone
to find and I know I'm not alone because
data Brokers are profiting from your
data selling it to robocallers spammers
pretty much anyone who's buying it but
you have the power to take control of
your Online safety with aura the sponsor
of today's episode Aura identifies data
Brokers that have your info and submits
opt-out requests on your behalf Brokers
are legally required to remove your info
if you ask them to but they make it
super hard to do it but Aura can handle
everything for you so you can spend your
time focusing on other tasks with peace
of mind Aura is like your personal line
guardian and it does more than just
identify data Brokers this is a
user-friendly service that includes
features like parental controls
antivirus VPN password management and
identity theft Insurance all in one
place and at a fair price to get started
go to aura.com what if or click on the
link in the description to get a
two-week free trial you know with aura
you can safely navigate the digital
world too bad there's no such service
for navigating in space
when Elon Musk sent his Tesla into space
it's likely he wasn't taking the best
protection measures against
interplanetary contamination and as more
and more commercial space launches
happen that could become the norm
the reality is that it would be nearly
impossible not to contaminate space it's
already too late
take for example a privately launched
Israeli lunar lander that crashed on the
moon in 2019 it was carrying thousands
of microscopic organisms called
tardigrades
they are known to be able to withstand
extreme conditions like freezing
temperatures and high radiation
they could be up there on the moon
plotting their Revenge right now
some microorganisms can grow and evolve
in microgravity or in conditions similar
to The Martian permafrost
that means we need to take every
precaution to avoid forward
contamination
and before you ask me what any of this
has to do with destroying life on Earth
well just wait
things are about to get dangerous
but first how do we avoid this forward
contamination
well we should start with rigorous
chemical cleaning and heat sterilization
to kill any life on the outside of our
spaceships
just make sure you step far away from
this process
and as we envision human crude missions
to Mars we should set up strict policies
about where we can land and explore long
before we go there
we should establish exploration zones
where we could contaminate in a
controlled manner then we'd apply
stricter precautionary measures before
we explored other parts of the red
planet
but it's not forward contamination that
should scare you
in these outer space missions we could
accidentally pick up extraterrestrial
life and bring it back to Earth
these microbes entering our biosphere
could pose existential threats to all
kinds of organisms ourselves included
finding Life on Mars either fossilized
or Alive seems pretty slim but it's
possible that life forms could survive
in the water-rich spots on the planet
these Martian organisms may have the
same biological origin as life on Earth
now that sounds cool but that's what
would make them dangerous
because it's more likely that these
extraterrestrial microbes would find
Earth to be a hospitable new home
if this was the case there's a chance
that these invasive space microbes might
slowly take over our Blue Marble
they could force many species of plants
and animals into Extinction
humans too and that's because they could
be pathogens
those are organisms like parasites fungi
or viruses and they need a host to do
their thing a host like you
and because these parasites are out of
this world they could be resistant to
your immune system's responses
they'd quietly replicate and spread
inside your body until they were ready
to come out
one day you'd cough up a yellow mucus
maybe an oxygen-loving mucus that would
start growing and spreading all around
you
this alien monstrosity could grow as
fast as one meter in one day
soon it might develop a fruiting body
with deadly spores inside of it
eventually this thing would burst open
releasing thousands of spores
now this would be one thing if it
happened in an isolated lab but if this
monstrosity exploded outside in the open
well there's nothing we could do to stop
alien spores from spreading and
infecting everything in their way
that's game over for Earth
better to eradicate these microbes
quickly before they could wipe us out
and that's why we need strict rules and
protocols for returning spacecraft their
crew and any potential biological
samples they may carry
in past Apollo missions astronauts were
quarantined for 30 days after returning
to Earth and all the lunar samples they
brought were subjected to extensive life
detection and biohazard protocols
if you were transporting samples from
Mars well you should assume they're
dangerous until it's clear they're not
that means proper containment
and that containment should stay intact
throughout your spacecraft's travel
re-entry into Earth's atmosphere and
delivery to quarantine facilities
you should only distribute the samples
once scientists have proven that they
don't contain any biological life
if there's even a slight uncertainty
that the samples weren't properly
contained
well they and the entire spacecraft must
be sterilized while still in space
and if there's still doubt
well sorry your spaceship could never
return to Earth
yep you should turn around and get ready
to settle down on Mars permanently
but that's a story
for another
what if